in other news today victim says that she
is well devastated and her supporters
are very angry after a controversial
plea bargain in an alleged rape case
Jacob Anderson he's a former fraternity
president at Baylor University he was
accused of raping a teenage sophomore
back in 2016 he will avoid jail time
after pleading to a lesser charge of
unlawful restraint in a deal that was
approved by a judge who was allowed
light sentences in other cases involving
sexual assault allegations Omar
Villafranca at the courthouse in Waco
Texas was more on this story Omar the
people are very angry about this good
morning to you good morning the judge in
this case Ralph Struthers says that
Anderson must undergo counseling and pay
a $400 fine the 23 year old also faces
three years of deferred probation but he
does not have to register as a sex
offender and there are many people who
were worried about the message that this
punishment sentence Jacob Anderson had
little to say as he left a Waco
courthouse Monday after being spared
prison time despite being indicted on
four counts of sexual assault his
alleged victim told police in 2016 the
former Baylor fraternity president
repeatedly raped her at an off-campus
house party where alcohol was served
she says he gagged and choked her until
she lost consciousness following
Monday's plea agreement the woman known
as Donna Doe addressed the judge in
court I am devastated by your decision
he stole my virginity and power over my
body and you let him keep it for all
eternity do the women on campus talk
about this yeah
Baylor graduate student Erin Alban
started an online petition expressing
outrage over the deal more than 85,000
people have signed it why do you think
there was that much response I think
people are finally realizing that this
is a problem and that survivors aren't
taken seriously should we see time and
time again everything from the national
level down to the local level of
a lot of people mainly men getting away
with things like this this is at least
the third time judge Strasser has
approved probation for men accused of
sexually assaulting Baylor students once
after a guilty plea in a 2013 rape case
and another earlier this year that
included a 30 day jail sentence served
on weekends in a statement Monday
prosecutor Hillary Laborde said
Anderson's plea deal was the best
outcome given the facts of the case
conflicting evidence and statements
exist making the original allegation
difficult to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt she says all the facts must be
considered and there's information that
hasn't been made public the new Varghese
is a former prosecutor in these type of
cases unless you've had a body cam on
both these individuals from start to
finish recording not only the video but
were the audio none of these cases will
never be cut and dry in court the judge
says there is a lot of information the
public just does not know about this
case so we reached out to the judge but
he did not return our calls or emails
now in Texas unlawful restraint is a
third degree felony meaning that
Anderson faced a possible sentence of
two to 10 years had he been convicted of
that charge Nora
Omar thank you I think people are gonna
start looking into this judge and some
of the rulings he's had in the past and
based on the facts that we're hearing
about the case it really doesn't make
any sense it would be nice if he does do
an interview just to explain what he's
thinking yeah but you're right Nora then
this story isn't over
[Music]